guys you were both there last year when
Dylan Brooks said what he said about
LeBron and we saw the way LeBron
responded last year I don't know that
I've ever seen him do like a twoo small
on the court um did you see a different
juice in him today and I guess beyond
that can you just sort of speak to the
run that he's been on to start the
year I mean I I don't know what's the
what are the like what's the beef
between those two guys but you know I
know they've been doing it for a while
you know especially last year the
playoffs you know um they had you know
things going on but you know you know
for for for bra you know it's nothing
you know it's just it's it's actually
good for him he he need that motivation
so you know it's actually bring him more
you know U to the game and as you guys
seen like you know it's whatever he's
doing and like it's it doesn't do
anything to him you know he actually
score more he's you know he gets rebound
more he you know and then we' been
winning so yeah so yeah it's a those are
things like you know just you you know
you know Brooks he he just want to you
know be part of it you know his his
legacy I guess you
know you want me to answer that was I
mean that was a good answer um I don't
know the one special thing about Brun is
um I was telling someone this other day
never really seen him in a bad mood uh
he's always got energy you know he's the
oldest player in the NBA but you know
still acts like he's 20 every day um
just joking around having fun um and I
think he plays the game the same way um
regardless of who he's playing and you
know like Rose said you know anytime
Braun has something that pushes him a
little you know further um you see the
results like you get tonight uh like
last year in the playoffs you know he
just did more after all that stuff
started
happening